et par ailleurs le redémarrage se fait
voler tout moins vite que dans d'autres
pays ainsi nous ne retrouverons notre
niveau de pib de 2019 que dans le cours
de l'année 2022 probablement entre mars
et août 2022 bon mais pas avant donc il
ya un vrai problème de ce point de vue
là il faut comprendre que évidemment
quand on a une chute très fort il est
assez normal qu'on ait une reprise forte
l'année d'après
et re bonsoir donc jacques merci d'être
avec vous ce soir on va passer au crible
ces bons chiffres du chômage
clairement est ce que ces chiffres ils
sont justifiés cet optimisme actuelle du
gouvernement en matière d'économie et il
faut alors il est très clair que au
troisième trimestre la situation a été
bien meilleurs que prévu on le voit sur
la baisse du nombre de demandeurs
d'emploi pas exactement les chômeurs on
le voit aussi sur le redémarrage de
l'économie bon ça c'est une chose qui
est avérée après la question que sa peau
c'est un est-ce que ça va au delà de la
fameuse catégorie a et ça c'est une
vraie question parce que si la situation
était aussi bonne qu'on le prétendait et
bien il y aurait une forme de diffusion
deuxièmement et bien cette espèce de
relance que l'on a alors même si on
reste en dessous du chiffre de la baisse
de l'année dernière et bien cette
relance elle est assez normal et est ce
qu'elle est suffisante pour nous
permettre de surmonter le choc de
l'année dernière ça c'est encore une
autre question et enfin il ya toujours
cette question qui se pose est ce que ça
peut durer et là malheureusement on voit
qu'il ya des nuages noirs qui
s'accumulent sur l'horizon économique
alors qu'en est il de cette baisse du
chômage alors sur la baisse du chômage
il faut dire elle ne concerne
pratiquement que ce qu'on appelle la
catégorie a dans les données de la dares
ou de pôle emploi alors la catégorie à
il s'agit des gens qui sont sans emploi
qui sont à la recherche active d'un
emploi
mais il faut faire attention ce ne sont
pas eux qui constituent à eux seuls
l'ensemble des chômeurs parce qu'on a
d'autres catégories par exemple vous
avez la catégorie b sont grosso modo des
gens qui travaillent moins de 10 heures
ou 20 heures par mois on voit très bien
qu'ils ne peuvent pas vivre avec ça donc
ils sont considérés en fait comme
chômeur ou comme demandeur d'emploi il
ya aussi d'ailleurs des d'autres
personnes qui sont tout simplement
exemptés de l'obligation de recherche
d'emploi pourquoi il s'agit par exemple
des femmes enceintes des personnes qui
sont temporairement malades bon ce que
l'on voit c'est que ces deux autres
catégories b et d dans le langage
technique de la dares et de pôle emploi
et bien non seulement elles ne
connaissent pas de baisse mais en fait
elle monte un petit peu ça c'est le
premier point deuxième point c'est quand
on regarde ce bloc de chômeurs à b et d
et puis ce qu'on peut considérer pour
parler un petit peu rapidement comme des
quasi chômeurs c'est à dire les
catégories c et e ce sont soit des gens
qui sont en stage de manière très
temporaire soit les gens qui ne sont pas
en plein emploi mais qui sont quand même
avec un emploi partiel un petit peu plus
que les 20 heures par mois précédent
bref sur les catégories c et e et puis
on voit que ça reste absolument stable
donc en réalité cette baisse du chômage
n'a correspondu ou troisième trimestre
qu'à la catégorie 1 est alors la
question évidemment à quoi sont dues ces
différences alors on peut le comprendre
assez simplement intuitivement
après le troisième confinement le
confinement du mois d'avril dernier bon
les entreprises ont rouvert elles ont
repris et elles se sont heurtées à un
mur de l'emploi c'est qu'elle avait
besoin de trouver des travailleurs quels
sont les premiers chômeurs qui peuvent
être employés à ça effectivement les
gens de la catégorie ya donc tout à fait
normal que ce soit eux qui soit allée
les premiers sur le marché de l'emploi
qu'ils soient rentrés sur le marché de
l'emploi est d'ailleurs de manière assez
importante 1
5,8 pour cent au troisième trimestre et
grosso modo 10 % sur un an après si le
phénomène devait durer et bien cela se
verrait par le fait qu'il perd collerait
dans les autres catégories or ce qu'on
voit aujourd'hui c'est que ça ne parle
pas ça ne conseille ça ne concerne que
la catégorie à donc c'est pour cela
qu'il y a un vrai problème alors jacques
pourquoi le gouvernement parle d'une
croissance inédite en france qui croire
ben écoutez si on pense si on regarde
les chiffres il n'a pas tort on est
entre 6 2 6 3 % de croissance sur 2011
sera quand on aura les chiffres du
quatrième trimestre bon c'est un très
beau résultat et c'est effectivement
l'un des meilleurs résultats
pratiquement depuis l'après guerre
maintenant quand on regarde la chute que
l'on a connu en 2020 en est loin du
compte on a eu un pib qui a baissé de 8%
il va augmenter d'à peu près 6 % l'année
suivante ben oui mais ça ne compense pas
les 8% perdu et d'ailleurs ce qui est
intéressant de voir c'est que quand on
regarde les données qu a collationné le
fonds monétaire international
sur la base des instituts des
gouvernements etc on voit que la france
a été l'un des pays qui a connu le choc
le plus important d'autres pays comme
par exemple l'allemagne la suède où les
états unis n'ont pas connu un choc de
même ampleur est par ailleurs le re
démarrage se fait plutôt moins vite que
dans d'autres pays ainsi nous ne
retrouverons notre niveau de pib de 2019
que dans le cours de l'année 2022
probablement entre mars et août 2022 bon
mais pas avant donc il ya un vrai
problème de ce point de vue là il faut
comprendre que évidemment quand on a une
chute très forte il est assez normal
qu'on ait une reprise forte l'année
d'après alors même réflexion qu'avant
quand on parlait du taux de pauvreté un
le gouvernement prétend que là encore
ces résultats sont le produit du quoi
qu'il en coûte
qu'est ce que vous en pensez c'est là où
je dirais le discours du gouvernement
est peut-être le plus critiquable parce
que formellement bien sûr quand on
gratte un petit peu les chiffres c'est
différent mais formellement il n'a pas
tort sur les autres questions après sur
le quoi qu'il en coûte ce que l'on voit
ce que oui bien sûr la france a plus
aider ces entreprises et sa population
que la moyenne de l'union européenne
mais moins que ses principaux
partenaires par exemple nous avons fait
entre les engagements budgétaires et les
garanties de prêts des garanties de
crédit nous avons fait environ 25% du
pib 1 l'allemagne est à 43 % 43 %
l'italie est à peu près au même niveau
la grande bretagne aussi et un niveau
très élevé alors ça prouve que d'abord
on en a fait peut-être moins que nos
voisins et en ski le plus intéressant
c'est que l'italie était dans une
situation financière en fait plus
dégradée que la france est pourtant il
on nous fait plus donc on voit bien que
ce n'est pas simplement le fait qu'on
était dans une situation dégradée qui
nous a retenus donc il ya un vrai
problème politique là et il faut
comprendre que quand le gouvernement dit
oui nous avons fait le quoi qu'il en
coûte nous sommes un exemple pour
l'ensemble de l'union européenne est
elle exacte ans avait rien en gros
jacques que ces hausses ces programmes
sont pas dues aux politiques des états
c'est ça alors je ne dis pas ça je dis
simplement qu'il ya des choix différents
qui ont été faits et que le choix qui a
été fait par le gouvernement français a
été un choix en fait de moindres
soutient que ce qu'a fait le
gouvernement allemand ce qu'a fait le
gouvernement italien ou que ce qu'a fait
le gouvernement britannique donc ça veut
dire que le gouvernement on a fait un
petit peu trop et trop tôt pour crier
victoire alors il en a fait pas assez et
ils crient pourtant victoire est là on
voit qu'il ya un vrai problème alors je
reprends un petit peu c'est que oui il
n'a pas tort de dire qu'effectivement le
troisième trimestre de 2021 a été bon on
le constate bien mais il faut comprendre
une chose hein sur la question du
chômage il n'y a pas de diffusion
de ce retour à l'emploi or la catégorie
à donc ça pose un véritable problème
ensuite on à la question de savoir
qu'est ce que c'est que ces
augmentations d'emploi et en fait on
voit que la france est restée dans son
modèle traditionnel autrement dit nous
sommes dans une économie de services les
emplois qui ont été recréés sont
essentiellement des emplois de service
des dalles à personne que ce soit aux
plus jeunes aux seniors et c'est avec
une baisse de la productivité qui
explique aussi cette forme de reprise de
l'emploi et qui va nous mettre en
difficulté
dans les années qui viennent par rapport
à nos voisins donc ça c'est un problème
important l'autre problème qui est très
important c'est de comprendre que la
situation économique globale est en
train en fait de se détériorer on voit
qu'il ya déjà des formes de
ralentissement en allemagne même en
italie ça commence à se voir et puis la
troisième question qu'est ce qui va se
passer du côté de la bce 1 dernièrement
madame christine lagarde a été très
attaqué par la presse allemande
d'ailleurs de manière pas très élégante
il faut il faut le dire qu'ils accusent
de ne pas mener la politique restrictive
que l'allemagne pense être nécessaire
alors effectivement si la bce change de
politique si par exemple en 2022 elle
commence à réduire fortement ses achats
de titres et elle commence à augmenter
ses taux et bien nous aurons pas du tout
dans une situation où la croissance de
la fin de 2021 pourra se poursuivre et
on pourrait même connaître une nouvelle
cure d'austérité et ça sera peut-être
l'objet de notre édito de la semaine
prochaine pas de votre édito en tout cas
merci j'accepte dire merci à vous donc
la semaine prochaine